-It is so great to see you.
You look fantastic.
-Thank you so much.
-I want to congratulate you,
because last time
you were on our show -- shortly
after you were on our show,
you did a one-woman play
off-Broadway
and got nominated for
all these awards for acting.
Congratulations on that.
-Thank you so much.
-It's a big deal.
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Can I just say that --
-That was really amazing and
challenging for me.
The most challenging thing
I've ever done in my career.
I mean, being -- And,
of course, a dream come true,
because an actress,
Mexican actress,
off-Broadway show,
you know, like,
talking about my own country,
about "Las Muertas de Juárez"
in English, which is not
my first language --
that was something
that I couldn't say no.
But then, when I said yes,
I wanted to die.
I was like, "How am I going to
pull this off?"
I thought I was not going to be
able to really --
to pull it off.
And they say I'm brave and
I'm tough and this and that
because I went to see El Chapo.
That was a walk in the park.
I mean...
-Really? Compared to this?
-Of course.
-Well, how many characters
were in --
-14.
-Kate, why would you do this
to yourself?
I mean, really.
-I don't know.
It's painful even now.
-But you crushed it.
-Thank you.
-Can I just say, you became
the first Mexican actor
to be nominated for
three American theater awards
in a single season.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is --
-Thank you.
-In history.
-Yes.
-"La Reina."
Can we talk about "La Reina,"
the Queen?
-Of course.
-Yeah. You're back.
Explain the story behind this,
because I know you came out.
You had one season.
It was a giant hit.
And then you
didn't come back for like
another couple years.
-10 years.
The first season,
and then, 10 years later,
we did the second season.
And I was like nobody is going
to remember "La Reina."
-But why did it take
that long to do?
-Because it was only one book.
So, it's based on a
novel written by
this amazing author from Spain
called Arturo Pérez-Reverte.
So it was only one book.
Why do a second season?
It was a great hit.
I was like, "Let's just leave it
as it is, and it's great.
But then, you know,
they get greedy, you know?
Those things --
-Yeah.
Yeah. It's making
a profit, yeah.
-And it was again a super hit.
And we -- You know, we were
number 1 in its time slot.
NBC, CBS,
like, we were the number 1.
Which is amazing to be --
I mean,
it's amazing to be right here
sitting with you,
promoting a
Spanish-speaking show.
I think that's amazing.
It wouldn't happen before.
-Yeah, I agree.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm happy about that.
-I appreciate that.
I appreciate that.
So, now we are doing Season 3.
And this one comes --
Like, it's the most ambitious.
-By the way, it's gorgeous.
Who is it behind it?
Telemundo and...
-Telemundo, Netflix.
-And Netflix.
Yeah, you can tell
there's some money behind this.
-There's a lot of money.
I mean, I can --
-It's really big budget.
-I know.
And it's 60 episodes,
and each episode
is better than the other one.
I'm like, "Oh, my God, this is
like a movie, every single one."
So I'm very excited for this --
-The locations.
-We got the Emmy
on the last season.
-That's right. Congratulations.
-Yeah.
-Did that feel good?
-That's got to feel good, right?
-Yeah, of course.
The International Emmys.
So, that's what I'm saying.
We're getting there, you know?
And Spanish-speaking shows,
actresses,
Mexican actresses --
we're getting there.
-You're breaking through.
-Yes.
-Can we say what's happening --
what's going to happen
this new season?
-We're staying away from
the narco-trafficking thing,
which I think is amazing.
Now it's more of
a political thriller.
Action. There's a lot of action.
There's -- We went to
five different countries.
You're going to see
a Latin America
that if you are not
Latin American,
you're going know what
Latin America is made of.
And if you're Latin American,
you're going to be
so proud,
because we're going to show
the magnificent Latin America
that we have.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-Yes!
-Yes, yes.
And amazing places.
We went to Bolivia.
We went to Peru.
We went to Argentina,
to Mexico, and Colombia.
So, yes.
-Oh, get ready.
You put the work in,
and it is fantastic.
I'm so happy that
you came back to our show.
-Yes, thank you.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Kate del Castillo
in the new season of
"La Reina del Sur."
Take a look.
-Let's go, let's go!
-Move, move!
-Come on, let's go!
-Hold your fire!
I want her alive!
Let's go! Go, go!
-I mean, come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are just the best. Come on.
Kate del Castillo, everybody!
"La Reina del Sur"
premieres October 18th
at 9:00 p.m. on Telemundo.